happy friday my friday friends i look
great
tonight's monologue is about priorities
the media's priorities the government's
priorities like there's any difference
there
and your priorities which don't matter
to them here's a fun story about new
york a thug knocks out a diner in an
unprovoked attack leaving him in a coma
with a fractured skull as i told you it
was fun
the attacker recently got out of prison
for rape
i know he's probably a victim of the
system and by system i mean what we used
to call law and order
so where is he now well after his charge
for attempted murder was downgraded to a
misdemeanor he's out on no cash bail
because trying to kill someone isn't
that much different these days than
loitering and now he's free to beat and
rape again
so audience have fun walking back to
your cars
because keeping him behind bars would
have made him the victim
and that's his job
making victims
so were we told that bail reform was
only for non-violent felonies but it's a
bait and switch like when i order steak
medium well and the waiter punches me in
the face instead
once again the politicians left-wing
da's and judges play russian roulette
with law-abiding citizens and every time
they pass something like bail reform
it's like they're adding another bullet
to the chamber of a gun pointed at your
head to them the city is just an
experimental aquarium so it's a few
piranhas as they hide in that castle in
the corner
so this rape fiend is out it's like the
da's are saying hey you got raped down
pretty well but you still need to work
on your murdering skills
so get out there and don't come back
until you get it right
you'd think mayor eric adams would be
all over this
but he does more lip service than
pelosi's plastic surgeon
yeah here's what he's up to
hey guys
[Applause]
it was all in the hips
so he dressed up as a construction
worker to destroy an outdoor dining shed
so first he was a cop now he's a
construction worker
anybody seeing a pattern here
i think we got a one-man village people
going on
so he took down the shed because people
were peeing in them
fair enough but if the mayor went around
smashing everything that's been peed on
in new york
there wouldn't be a thing left standing
including madonna
what do you mean i don't get it i don't
get that
now unless perps are disguising
themselves as sheds i question adam's
priorities
like brian stelter's cholesterol this is
not his biggest problem right now
[Applause]
people are being attacked and murdered
nero may have fiddled but eric's
hammering and what's the governor of new
york doing
she announced that she signed a bill
replacing the word salesman with sales
person
this to help women in the workplace
yeah some help she's a real leah thomas
rape is up 10
and she's replacing man with person
this is really her priority
9-1-1 what's your emergency i was just
assaulted by a salesman
you mean salesperson don't you
i'll send a squad car but not for him
ma'am for you
someone should remind the governor that
while jobs may not have genders victims
of violent crime do a lot of them are
women so whether it's salesman or
salesperson new yorkers shouldn't be
buying the
she's selling
this is the same idiot by the way who
replaced the word inmate with
incarcerated person
that helps
fine i'd love to call violent criminals
incarcerated persons
but none of them are incarcerated
anymore
i
i'd say the inmates are running the
asylum but i can't say inmates anymore
i don't want to get canceled
and i tell people to file a complaint
with the government but what good would
that do
hi so my sister and i were attacking the
subway and the state did nothing sounds
good here have your next to kin fill out
this form sign date notarize please
include two copies of your original
birth certificate vaccination card and
any coupons wait wait i want to speak to
a supervisor oh yes well there's a form
for that too
you'll need this
this
and these
thank you
hey i'm here to fill out my release form
oh no you're good we took care of it
okay
and
[Applause]
gun oh you use blue ink i can't accept
those you'll need to fill out a
mishandled form form let me see if i can
grab that and once i get that can i
submit all this at once sure
[Applause]
that should be up for an emmy
not you
but this is all fakery pointless virtue
signaling while cities crumble it's a
disease afflicting this entire country
thanks to a fake news media which
decides what's important and what's not
few stories are more relevant than blood
loss but now it's all things trump and i
get it he wrote mean tweets that kept
you up at night but last i checked he
isn't roaming the streets killing people
like those ms-13 gang members he once
called animals which upset pelosi to no
end remember that
none of those perps were orange
so as businesses close
so as businesses close and people leave
cities for the same reason they leave
cats apartment crime and decay
the media is focused on real brutality
like tax evasion which the cfo of the
trump organization pleaded guilty for
and surely the charge had absolutely
nothing to do with his association with
trump but this 75 year old dude he's
going to rikers island
the prison while attempted murderers
roam free
and why
because our media only cares about stuff
that has the smell of trump on it
including melania's clothes apparently
that's all right
knock it off
literally you don't rate the news media
knows trump hate pays the bills not
stories that actually affect your lives
besides on the punishment spectrum it's
the thugs who are oppressed and you
who's the oppressor the fact is until
these left-wing leaders feel the
real-life experience of actual crime
they're not going to care
governor abbott sent migrants to liberal
cities so they could feel the
consequences of their policies
it's time to do that with thuggery
i'd love to send the freed violent
felons to the burbs of the judge the
da's who freed him he'll i'll pay for
the uber
but
of course i can't do this because if
something happened to the judge or the
soros-funded d.a i'd be an accessory and
that's my point
i'd be just like the judges and the da's
when every time one of these mutts they
they let loose again hurt somebody else
their accessories too
it's a shame they don't get the credit
his razors go great with his comedy both
make you want to slash your wrists
westernrazer.com owner and a comedian
david angelo
he's my favorite shannon
gop u.s senate candidate from oklahoma
t.w shannon
her two least favorite words are last
and call
fox's contributor
and finally he has to play monopoly with
real houses my massive sidekick in the
nwa's world television
welcome to the show david it's been a
while it has been thanks for having me
back oh my pleasure my pleasure wasn't
my choice but
well we always do what we can when
somebody good drops out and we need to
find a replacement nearby
right and you know you because you work
at that uh yeah i live down the street
yeah you come here real no problem yeah
exactly stand out in front of the
audience waiting in line hoping you get
recognized yeah come on guys
walk right by is crime impacting your
razor business
no that's a good question though greg
because we are america's largest
american-made razor
you know everything's done here in the
country but we fortunately we haven't
been impacted that way
i live in new york
the thing about crime is
why can't they like it'd be one thing if
the rents went down with it but the rent
keeps going up yeah
you know
can we get the i mean i don't i wouldn't
mind the crime if i could get the rent
lower right you know what i mean yeah
you'll take the risk yes you'll take the
risk for the cheaper uh
payment however the rents go up because
people stay more in their house
so maybe they're willing to pay more i'm
just saying you could push me in the
subway tracks if i could afford any unit
washer dryer
that's all i'd want do you still go to
the laundromat
no come on that's a joke
you're a
jerk you know tw
it's kind of do you get the impression
that there's no going back in the sense
that somehow once you accept a certain
level of degradation people lying on the
streets passed out uh
recidivism out of control that it's kind
of like how do you get the genie back in
the bottle yeah well i think the first
thing you got to realize greg this is
not by hopping circumstances not just
gross negligence and incompetence i
think this is a deliberate effort to
undermine the republic the liberal
agenda is pretty clear they want you
know they they're against police they're
against uh the idea of guns and they're
certainly against you know securing our
border we need to secure our border
we've got way too much crime we had
enough chinese fentanyl coming to this
country to kill every american seven
times but tw that sounds well and dandy
for maybe fox and friends
but um you know liberals have kids
liberals go to work liberals get mugged
but they're not mugged by reality yet
but but they don't live remember the
democrat party what it's become and it's
become the party of rich liberals and
you know a few poor people that they
require to stay poor so that they can
stay rich i mean the truth is this party
uh has lost it's gone off the rails a
long time ago and uh the only way we get
back is getting back to the things that
make this country great and it's really
about the constitution it's about
capitalism it's about christianity i
would take that's what made the country
i would take more cops i take more cops
too yeah but that's constitutional
[Applause]
hey what's going on over there tyrus
chillin gutfelt yeah yeah
oh man my boy the mayor i know he's
plant-based but the brother might want
to get a steak in there after seeing
that
you would see how the board just the
board wasn't even nailed i remember when
he was running i was like oh man i can
get behind this dude i don't care what
his politics are because he's tough yeah
and
i might one time or another may be
involved in simulated combat
wrestling for you lay persons um
we would call that a blown spot
i mean he had all the accoutrement
which is something that only the
elitists do he had to have the new
helmet he had to have the best
he had to have the matching outfit
he had to have the finest hammer
until he swung the hammer and realized
this is heavy
so what what he did was he yelled cut
and then the real construction workers
came in and set up the ta the wall for
him so he could do his plant-based swing
and knock over the wall causing all of
us to go
what was
that that is an example of what is wrong
it's the same thing when they keep
changing the name so you know what
calling somebody a white supremacist or
racist affair we're going to call them a
one race enthusiast
[Laughter]
so everyone's included but this is this
is the issue they're they focus on the
wrong things and they think we don't see
it's so funny brother get a steak just i
think he's mistaken he's like gym tough
right you could tell he's like he's the
guy who does the curls
but when it comes to the free weights
he's got to go stretch
i don't even know what that means
you know kat uh are you relieved to know
that sales man is now salesperson has
that
are you gonna sleep better at night much
much less frightening the potential of
getting raped
it's crazy and i agree with you uh david
angelo
that if the rent wasn't so bad but also
the taxes weren't so high yes what are
you paying for what am i paying for i'll
give you an example of what i'm paying
for they just opened a park by my
apartment the city opened a park guess
how many times we went there before we
before we saw a bum taking a dump in the
bushes once first time yes
and there's a public bathroom right
there he wanted to do that yes exactly i
i just i wouldn't mind you know like if
i'm going to be paying this much i want
to live somewhere where more people use
toilets more often yes
no sanctuary for public pooping
we should have we should declare a
neighborhood sanctuary city for toilets
if you want to use the toilet you can
live in this neighborhood
you know i know a lot of people in the
audience they're maybe not from here but
when you you can walk outside right now
there are people passed out in front
on 6th avenue there is a guy a guy who
burned down our christmas tree remember
that he's outside yeah
i got a picture on my phone
i'm not gonna tell you where he is but
that this is insane
arsonist
arsonist person arsonist person
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else